it was like
mouth olympics i for the for the it's um
for the first
like two weeks leading into
the first day of shooting i had really
bad tmj because i think i was having
like just physical manifestations of
fear genuine fear of failure
and uh
kind of just what the whole thing was
gonna be as an experience was gonna be
cold and heavy and long
[Music]
hi i'm pablo lahren i'm the director of
spencer hi i'm kristen stewart and this
is how we found our way into the
character of princess diana
we've set up uh
a list of ideas books and and articles
that that we all had so that was the
start of the of the process but then
kristen went
way further and started reading a lot
more and ultimately i believe that each
of us had a kind of a different approach
and process i
i had a longer one because of i've been
with the movie for longer than christian
but when kristen got in i think yours
was very intense too so i won't speak
for you but but i think there are many
many ways to to to get into the
character and what i think is
fascinating is that after
reading after watching movies and
documentaries and of course the crown
and other things and after making the
movie i think that i don't really know
who she really was
and that is a very interesting thing for
a movie because it just can't you can't
really capture her the amount of
research to sift through is fast and i
think initially we had conversations
about it not being
paramount to our experience knowing
every detail and he said she said kind
of things because at some point we did
have a conversation about it becoming
too much that it would start to weigh
you down trying to encompass everything
at once when what we're doing is
kind of living in the in between and the
grayness and the ambiguity and the
emotion of her and kind of what she
instills in people in a more vague sense
because i think that all of those
details are well covered and actually as
a cumulative memory
that our society has of her anyone
watching the movie you bring all the
things that you know about her to the
film we know she died in a car accident
tragically way too young at the end of
the movie that's all anyone's thinking
about we don't need to say it there are
so many things that we don't need to say
so
when he was like dude you don't have to
read absolutely everything just like get
into her absorb her emotionally i just
wanted to sort of find as many i became
enthralled with the story admittedly in
every way that everyone has across the
world you know the royal family has
endured our curiosities for ever and i
was totally wrapped up in that i
couldn't stop reading i couldn't stop
reading all the sort of things that went
against each other and all the
contradictions and
different impressions of her
it wasn't about being any type of
authority on her life it was just about
feeling as close to her as possible and
just feeling like there were certain
things that made me laugh made me angry
made me cry and they were all kind of
attached to things that i learned about
her or stories anecdotes that i heard
moments of her
in interviews where you just feel like
you can see her yeah just kind of became
obsessed but the actual preparation of
like the actual acting of her there's no
way to describe why or how it was just
sort of like okay script's really good
just go give it a shot
that's what helped me a lot um i don't
know about you but it was seeing
pictures of her i think her relationship
with fashion it's very interesting and
speaks about herself too i think the way
that she wore certain things and when
and how is very interesting and she
she's communicating with those yeah
she's trying to reach out and like
cryptically say lots of things
and the use of color and something that
we discussed the jacket jackie and duran
a lot it was
how she would choose certain colors for
certain occasions
and that was so interesting and and
that's it's something that is more
internal that it's not
you can't really talk about it because
it's like music and colors and we can't
even know for sure it's like
it would be so fun to be able to be like
the day that you wore that red chanel
were you did you feel like you needed to
be strong that day she i would love to
be able to know like what her team was
talking about behind closed doors being
like we got you big we're going to get
you ready you're going to look kill her
we're going to send you out there and
she's like okay i think i need to wear
the thing that makes me feel the best
you know i mean but she would she would
wear red for church right she could she
would she would go
on black for
certain occasions she would she would be
on on light blue for
to have a walk the combination she was
always creating a contrast
with the situation and and how she were
and that speaks i feel that it's
reactive but it's not just arbitrary
yeah yeah and it's so incredible that's
as part of her her first perspective is
so interesting you're our highness
mommy
family are all gathered in the drawing
room
they are waiting
i got lucky because those kids are
wonderful and sweet and open and smart
they were really excited to to be with
us and um they know more about the royal
family than i do i think they're they're
from there and they're kind of steeped
in that culture and
so they brought a lot of their own
personally embedded connection to the
story which was really interesting they
improvised a little bit in the scene
with the candlelight in the most
impressive and astute way that almost it
feels like you're like whoa
this writing i mean this is going to
seem so self-aware but actually it's
really interesting to imagine be
self-referential because i'm sure that
at some point people like that do have
the conversations that you imagine they
might have like do you actually want to
be the king do you want to be the queen
those questions are in a hypothetical
world where we're allowed to dream about
these people that we fantasize about
it's just so interesting to be like wow
they probably did have that conversation
at some point together you know so in
working with them like i i had a lot of
help from pablo i'm intimidated by kids
i'm the youngest in my family i don't
have them yet he's just go i don't know
you're chill and cute and good with them
and so i was like
we became friends we all became friends
really quickly and i think they wanted
to we all wanted to love each other and
it worked it just it um
yeah just worked
three days
that's it
it was like
mouth olympics i
for the it's um
for the first like two weeks leading
into the first day of shooting i had
really bad tmj because i think i was
having like just physical manifestations
of fear genuine fear of failure
and uh
kind of just what the whole thing was
gonna be as an experience was gonna be
cold and heavy and long
the way that she speaks is so
loaded
her casual sort of disarming
quick fire
flitty buoyant bubbly voice sometimes
behind that is this shaky broken damaged
thing that you're like those things do
not go together it's such a complicated
way of expressing because she was never
really in a position to freely and very
honestly just say what is whenever me
and william sat down and watched her we
were always trying to figure out like
sure she's saying that but what is she
feeling and and what does she we're just
trying to sort of solve the puzzle of
her which is impossible but
she speaks so quickly sometimes
sometimes her voice is locked inside of
her body and sometimes it feels like it
floats in front of her like air like
there's just there are so many different
ways that she spoke whether she was in
private in public doing an interview
talking to fans uh talking to a family
member like her voice changed so often i
think there was so much to absorb when
watching her it wasn't like you can't
just i mean it's easy to do like your
best diana by putting your chin down and
kind of opening your eyes really wide
and
saying like no but but the hardest stuff
is when she's rattling off or when she's
angry or when she's laughing
to laugh as another person the thing
that everyone says about her that knew
her is that it erupted from somewhere
inside of her that felt like completely
untouchable and spontaneous and just
like suddenly it would come out of
nowhere and no one else would be
laughing and she would just be like kind
of cackling in the room
and there's like a manic energy to her
at times that feels kind of wild and
like you don't know what's gonna happen
and there's no way to play all of those
things at once in the first few days of
filming he had to come up to me and say
like you have to relax like
you can't try and shove everything
you've learned about this person or
everything that you like about her into
one moment it needs to sort all of these
things need to find themselves naturally
throughout the next three months
and um
yeah i think kind of when i let go of
the research is is when
it started to just kind of
by default find its way into my body but
i was very impressed from the very
beginning i remember putting my
headphones down after some shakes and
looking to william or that coach i was
like wow
and it was very it made me actually
nervous at some point when she was so
into it it was so
spot on as you say
and we actually start making fun of
certain ideas online
we're not going to repeat it here but
but it was it was incredible to see and
it's just so beautiful the one joke that
i will say like obviously it's a
slippery slope to make fun of this woman
but i was making fun of myself the whole
time it's just diana you have to stop
wandering the grounds
i was just wandering the grounds for
three months i was like pablo we need to
go inside
like we have to stop diana go home and
get some sleep
it's the boss
it's bad yeah
that's so good
mommy what's happened to make you so sad
well yeah
there is no future past and the present
is the same thing
diana
they can't change you have to change
[Music]
you have to be able to do things you
hate you hate there has to be two of you
it's the real one
and the one thing take pictures
diana for the good of the country
you